dylan roof dylan roof is the guy who
murdered a bunch of black people in a
church in in cold blood he knew some of
these people but he had these sort of
racial theories that he was he's a white
supremacist type guy and so he just goes
in in cold blood murders them all and he
is convicted of this and then he's
sentenced to death
then he appealed his death sentence
and then it was affirmed yesterday he
will be placed on death row and
ultimately executed by the state
now i noticed something there there were
some people
who said i oppose the death penalty and
i oppose the death penalty even for
dylan roof but for most people when i
see most of the commentary on this
popular and otherwise it was people
saying something to the effect of look i
oppose the death penalty
but there are exceptions
yeah we're getting yeah i oppose the
death penalty except for this guy yeah
i'm not going to miss this guy and i i
just think they're missing the point
entirely that's actually the worst take
you can possibly have on the death
penalty in my view
because
i'm very pro-death penalty i'm pro-death
penalty for the people who are convicted
of their capital offenses and sentenced
to it
including dylann roof
i'm pro-death penalty because i think
that it's good for
the question of justice i think it helps
society to understand justice i think it
meets out the just retribution for the
people who have committed the offenses i
think it it offers a deterrent effect
especially when it is carried through
and i think by the way it's
rehabilitative because hanging
concentrates the mind i think that the
death penalty when it is just in a just
system
is
totally right i am in agreement here
with
the bible i'm in agreement here with
saint paul with the great doctors of the
church saint thomas aquinas among many
others and i am in agreement with many
many many popes throughout history if
that sort of thing is persuasive to you
including the popes saints and including
a
beatified pope who carried out the death
penalty ordered the death penalty
himself in the papal states i think it
is totally a hard locked case for the
death penalty
and yet
the argument against the death penalty
is just revenge i don't think it's
revenge i don't think it's vengeance i
think it's just punishment i think the
state does not carry the sword in vain
but the people who say i oppose the
death penalty except for
this guy
they are engaging in revenge right i
mean they are they are actually
proving their own point on the death
penalty at least as as regards their
view of it
the reason that they
are especially upset with dylann roof is
because he's committed this special
crime of white supremacy but if the
situation were reversed if it were a
black supremacist or something killed a
bunch of white people i strongly suspect
they wouldn't they wouldn't make a big
deal and actually i know that because in
the capital offenses that
do fall closer to those lines they
usually stay mum
this is very bad we either need to have
a standard
of justice or we're just going to
descend into various interest groups
clamoring for revenge not not a very
good situation for society which
unfortunately is the way that we're
going
hey there before you go
if you liked this video please leave me
a comment just a little hey michael i
like this
hey michael nice hair hey buddy cool
sweater just whatever you want you can
also subscribe to the michael knowles
show apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcast head on over to it right now
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]